Ờ Ồ có bạn
đã bạn đã ă sẵn rồi
Ờ
tiêu đề khá là ngắn gọn để mình ghi này
hôm nay
livestream hôm nay
sẽ
tục làm pan
cham
làm web chên show nhé
vậy à
Ừ Thực ra là em xem video từ buổi hôm
trước ấ thì sẽ thấy là thực ra là anh ng
dự định kiểu
kiểu quay lại làm rất nhiều thứ rồi Ờ từ
lâu rồi chứ không
phải lần cuối livestream cũng một năm
trước mà đúng không ạ
Ờ gần như là dự định lần này quay lại
chắc là để kiểu bắt tay vào làm lại
những cái mà đang còn gian giở bởi vì
mình có rất có dự định làm rất nhiều thứ
chứ không phải là mỗi pancham này
pancham này chỉ là bây giờ nó là việc
đang ưu tiên cần làm thôi chứ dự định
mình làm Nói chung là kiểu mình thì có
khá nhiều ý tưởng ấy chẳng qua là hồi
trước thì đúng là rất là bị bận và bị
cuốn theo rất nhiều thứ thế mà bây giờ
không phải là rảnh hơn thôi nhá Mà bây
giờ mình thấy mình cũng phải sắp xếp lại
thời gian để mà thực hiện những cái gọi
là đam mê ngoài nữa ví dụ tôi đam mê dậy
này tôi đam mê làm những cái tiện ích
khác này chứ không phải chỉ có mỗi lần
mỗi lần kiểu ừ à không phải mỗi việc dậy
gọi là đi làm hàng ngày đi làm hàng ngày
đấy Thực ra thì may mà Ừ thì làm được
trình vẫn là đam mê
vẫn vẫn được gặp những đồ nghiệp tốt
kiểu học hỏi được nhiều nhưng mà tính ra
thì gọi nhở nó không phải là Tuy là công
ty cũng là product tức là bản thân mình
vẫn đang làm cái gọi là sản phẩm à của
Cứ cho là của mình đi nghĩa là công ty
đang làm của mình nhưng mà nó vẫn không
thc sự dù thế nào nữa nó vẫn không thực
sự là của mình mà đúng không nó vẫn là
của công ty và cái việc
là vì nó là của công ty nên thành ra là
nó sẽ không thể tùy ý theo ý mình và
chưa kể là công ty tôi làm về trang
thương mạnh điện tử về cơ bản thì nó là
à Cái thứ tôi ghét này ấy trong web bán
hàng kiểu
thế cái A cái mong muốn tôi là làm rất
nhiều tiện ích kiểu Tôi học công nghệ
ông tin này Thực ra thì tôi không biết
kể mấy ông chưa thì cái biệt danh bác
học điên của tôi ở trên Facebook mà có
lý do của nó cả Đó là hồi bé Tôi muốn
làm tôi muốn học rất nhiều để trở thành
một kỹ sư cơi để mà kiểu dạm như là mấy
ông kỹ sư ở bên B khoa ấy kiểu cơ khí
kiểu ờ muốn phát minh sáng chế ra rất
nhiều thứ để mà hỗ trợ cho kiểu đời sống
các thứ thứ nhưng mà về sau tôi cảm thấy
là kỹ sư hay là nhà Hoa học các thứ thứ
không được coi trọng Tại ít nhất là tại
Việt Nam kiểu dạng là lẫn cả là bâ ông
phát minh hay nghĩ ra cái gì đó tốn kém
các thứ mà trong khi đó tôi có rất nhiều
ý tưởng trong đầu đấy nên là Tôi cảm
thấy là khi mà tôi biết đến ngành này
tôi thỏa sức sáng tạo thỏa sức làm mọi
thứ mà không bị tôn kém gì cả thì về cơ
bản thì làm phần mềm mà nghĩa cùng lắm
là mình chỉ tốn thời gian để ngồi codt
ra thôi và người ta chỉ vi tải về sử
dụng được luôn trên mọi thiết bị của họ
chứ không cần phải kiểu mua của mình hay
vân vân mình phải mất tiền cho nguyên
liệu các thứ máy móc mấy không hiểu cái
của tôi không ạ Đấy và nó vẫn phục vụ
cho đời sống mọi người chẳng qua là trên
trên thế giới ảo thôi
tôi hỗ trợ bạn đấy sửa câu truy vấn SQL
Ờ có vẻ bạn đấy đang on luôn đây để tôi
mở cho mấy ông xem luôn
bài chữa nên là mấy ông tranh thủ có thể
hỏi đây tôi sẽ tạo cái th để mà để mấy
ông mấy ông vào đây hỏi hỏi đáp ở trong
này
Ờ Cái này hy vọng là nó không có gì đó
nhạy cảm Ờ vì Chắc là nhìn qua thì có vẻ
là chắc là đồ án bạn ấy thôi
Ờ ok để tôi xem
thử chắc không bị virus được cái link
này
nhá À đây có thể zoom đây
lên đầu tiên thì có gì
đây gắn phòng
à chưa Chị thấy có gì đó Sai sai rồi này
Ờ sao lại gắn Phòng nhỉ đặt phòng
phòng à Ý ông là ý ông đấy là kiểu một
lần đặt phòng thì đặt được nhiều phòng
thì cái này nó sẽ là hóa đơn này tổng số
phòng tổng số phòng ra cũng không cần
lắm Thôi kệ ờ trạng thái đơn tiền cọc
tổng tiền đại khái cái này hóa đơn
này Còn Đây là kiểu hóa đơn chi tiết này
kiểu kể thế
giản theo kiểu là giá
phòng à đây vẫn có giá phòng chung ở đây
à nĩa tách ra loại Phòng từng loại phòng
có giá như này mình sẽ nối nế Thế thì để
mà nối để lấy được giá để lấy được giá
thì sẽ phải nối từ đặt phòng gắn phòng
phòng xu nối sang bên
này mỗi khi tính toán thì làm như thế đó
và về sau sẽ ra được tổng
tiền Ok thô thường là mình sẽ lấy được
mình nên lưu luôn giá phòng tại cái lúc
gắn phòng thì nó hợp lý
hơn
trạng thái phòng ừ hiy vọng là bạn này
lưu trạng thái phòng là theo kiểu thường
là tôi sẽ lưu dạng là kiểu như tôi hướng
dẫn mấy ông một là lưu kiểu i5 hai lưu
kiểu in rồi tự mình tự mình kiểu kiểu tự
mình quy ước xem là số 1 là nghĩa là gì
số hai nghĩa gì giống kiểu status ấy ảnh
phòng tex
luôn
Thực ra 50 50 lắm Bởi vì thực ra thực tế
là em đang không hề lưu lại cụ thể xem
là là bạn đấy đặt cái phòng kiểu dạng là
loại phòng tại thời điểm Đấy là loại
phòng loại phòng gì giá báo nhiêu ở ngay
đây đương nhiên em thể nối sang nhưng mà
ở đây nha Ờ
Hôm qua tôi cũng nghĩ lại về cái vụ
chất là tôi dạy mấy ông đang
là thiết kế sơ đ thể đúng không s ra cơ
sở liệu đúng không và nó là đã được
chuẩn hóa nếu mà ông không nhớ chuẩn hóa
là gì Thì đại khái là kiểu dạng là mình
không lưu thừa dữ liệu sang bảng khác
đúng không Nhưng thực tế là rất nhiều
lúc chúng ta phải chấp nhận là không
chuẩn hóa tức là đây đây tôi thử ví dụ
cho mấy ông dễ hình dung
nhá bỏ qua về vụ này thì ví dụ dễ hình
dung giả sử ở đây có
ờ hơi có điểm danh đi điểm danh tôi có
thường là có mã sinh viên Giả sử thế
đúng không đấy để biết được điểm danh
bạn nào đúng không Đấy Và đây là sinh
viên
này
Ờ thường là sinh viên này sẽ có mã lớp
đúng không đ biết là thuộc lớp nào lớp
này và có mã khóa này và đây sẽ là khóa
đúng chư đấy thì để sinh viên này biết
được sinh viên thuộc khóa nào thì đôi
khi phải nối đến lớp lớp nối đến mã khóa
kiểu như này đúng không và để điểm danh
này biết được là điểm danh này là của
lớp nào thì đôi khi phải nối giữa mã
sinh viên xong rồi sinh viên rồi đến lớp
đấy mà nếu mà để để mà ông xem là trong
khóa này
có có những bạn sinh viên nào hay nghỉ
học Ui giời ôi thì ông phải nối giữa
sinh viên nối lớp nối khóa thì ông thấy
là nếu mà cho cho CH nhiều như thế ông
bị vỡ trận luôn ngoài việc là nó bị D
Kate dữ liệu ra vân vân trong trường hợp
này chắc không n vi kết nhưng mà thứ hai
đó
là mấy ông nghe thấy có ổn không không
đúng không
đấy Thì bây giờ mình cách xử lý là như
nào thì thực ra thực tế thực tế đó là
khái mấy ông sẽ phải biết thêm khái niệm
thực tế nữa Ngoạ đương nhiên là mấy ông
vẫn phải biết chuyển hóa nhá Nhưng mà
tôi cái nói chung là từ cái playlist này
đổ đi là tôi sẽ dạy mấy ông theo kiểu là
cũng Junio đến sho được chưa ạ sẽ có lúc
tôi sẽ quay lại dạy Junior professor thì
lúc đấy thì mấy ông gọi là gọi là kiểu
mấy ông sẽ thì nó sẽ là kiểu một cái
playlist khác còn playlist bây giờ nó sẽ
là mấy ông thấy tôi đặt sợ playlist đánh
số ở nă rồi Tức là nó cũng là kiểu ông
phải học qua hết mấy cái playlist trước
đúng không ạ thì cái play này nó sẽ là
kiểu nó sẽ chuyên sâu hơn Khá là nhiều
nó thực tế hơn đấy thì cái bài toán thực
tế đó
là đó đó là kiểu dạng là
ờ sinh viên tại một thời điểm thì các
bạn chỉ thuộc một lớp thôi và thuộc một
khóa thôi đúng không Thì thì rõ ràng là
rõ ràng là các bạn hoàn thân h lưu lại
Ví dụ mã lớp là mã
khóa đi kèm nghĩa là chỉ Thực tế là nó
sẽ bị vi phạm quy tắc chuẩn hóa Tứ cả
Chỉ tự nhiên cái này hoàn toàn để lấy
được qua cái này mà tự nhiên bây giờ
mình lưu lại nó sẽ bị dư thừa về dữ liệu
và đôi khi bị bị gọi là gì nhỉ sai lệch
về dữ liệu gọi là dĩ biến V dữ liệu Tức
là sao giả sử mà sinh viên này đổi lớp
thì rõ ràng là là cái mã lớp này theo
sinh viên không đúng nữa hoặc sinh viên
đổi khóa nhưng mà chắc là trường hợp này
hiếm đổi lớp sinh viên trường hợp Cũng
hơi hơi hiếm nhưng thực ra là không sao
phí thực tế thực tế nhá kể cả cho sinh
viên có đổi lớp hoặc thậm chí sinh viên
đổi khóa thì thì cái cái này cái điểm
danh này bản chất điểm danh nó vốn đâu
phải thực thể đấy Cái thứ nhất nó chỉ là
mối liên hệ giữa giữa sinh viên với một
cái một cái gọi là cái một cái tính năng
một cái thao tác một cái hành động gì đó
tác động lên sinh viên rồi tác động lên
cái khác để tạo ra cái thằng điểm danh
này chứ nó phải thực thể đấy là cái thứ
nhất nhá thứ hai đó
là cái này bản chất nó vẫn chỉ là lưu
lại lịch sử chứ không phải là mình dùng
vào để đối chiếu để lấy ra dữ liệu Tức
là sao nghĩa là những cái lưu ại lịch sử
thì mình đương nhiên là cái việc lưu lại
lịch sử tại thời khắc đấy là ông đang
điểm danh sinh viên tại lớp đấy và khóa
đấy nó lại đang là đúng kể cả sinh viên
này về sau đổi lớp thì ông ông hoàn toàn
ví dụ ví dụ nhá Thế là có hai trường hợp
này xảy ra ờ Giả sử nhá À sinh viên a
học môn học môn nào đó đó ví dụ môn pp
đúng không ạ môn pp ở lớp lớp 1 đúng
không bà học được 10 buổi rồi bạn điểm
danh 10 buổi rồi sau bạn sang lớp lớp 2
Bạn bị chuyển sang lớp 2 lớp 2 thì bắt
đầu học đúng không Thì theo mấy ông sinh
viên đấy Có phải học lại từ đầu không
hay là nghỉ 10 buổi Xong rồi đến buổi
thứ 11 thì đi chẳng ai như thế đúng
không sinh viên Vẫn phải học lại đúng
không và điểm danh Lại Từ Đầu thì rõ
ràng là bản chất là cái điểm danh đấy
của sinh viên đấy thì sẽ gắn với cái lớp
cũ thôi chứ không phải là nó sẽ đổi s
lớp mới vàh viên Đấy MC định điểm danh
10 buổi rồi không cần phải nó nỉ 10 buổi
xong rồi buổi thứ 11 nó thể đi Thực ra
thì thc tế không biết các trường thế nào
nhưng mà có tôi biết thì có vài trường
là nó cũng sẽ nhân gọi là gọi là gọi là
hạn hu thì nó vẫn sẽo cho gọi là cho
phép kiểu sinh viên kiểu em học gần như
là xong môn này rồi thì em chỉ cần đi
thi thôi chẳng hạn không cần đi học nữa
cũng là một cách nhưng cái này nó Hãn
Hữu kết hợ việc là kết hợ việc là
kiểu Ờ thực tế nó không có nhiều như
thế và việc lưu lại điểm và khi mà kiểm
tra điểm danh ấ thích thì ông nếu mà ông
làm theo kiểu cách thứ hai đấy thì ông
chỉ
cần kiểm tra kiểm tra V việc sinh viên đ
theo sinh viên và mã môn thôi không cần
phải mã lớp nữa thì nó sẽ không ba không
bao giờ bị lỗi này xảy ra
ờ 10 buổi đi thi rồi á không rồi không
biết trường ông thế nào Trường tôi là 10
phải 18 đế 20 buổi một môn một môn nó
cũng nhiều phết nên là đấy nhưng mà nó
kiểu bị nửa nửa như thế thì mấy ông bắt
sinh viên phải thực ra là thực tế thì
sinh viên vẫn có thể nghỉ Chắc thế Không
biết
p Storm rồi plugin các thứ tí tôi chia
sẻ nhá Thực ra tôi từng chia sẻ rồi
nhưng mà Gần đây tôi cũng gọi là cài
thêm rồi làm thêm kiểu nói chung là thay
đổi nhiều nên chắc là tôi sẽ chia sẻ lại
ờ cho một năm trước Xem live của anh lúc
đó đang ad
frer
tôi vừa đọc cái bài đó là fre freeland
thì làm freeland để biết được giá trị
mình như thế nào cũng cái bài trên spum
cũng một góc nhìn hay phết tối Văn cũng
hay kiểu gần như là đấy thì cũng thực tế
mà kiểu bạn làm freeland thì ta trả trả
giá bạn như nào thì bạn biết được thực
sự là bạn đang ở vị trí nào đúng không
cũng không nhớ về lý thuyết lắm đâu Tôi
dạy mấy ông Thực ra là nó bị ít lý
thuyết và thực hành nhiều hơn ấy nên là
toàn bộ lý thuyết chắc là mấy ông vẫn sẽ
phải tự đọc sách với kiểu học trên
trường hay vân vân chứ tôi dạy mấy ông
thì nó vẫn là thực tế hơn vì bản thân tô
cũng học từ thực tế nhiều hơn ờ ừ quên
mất nói hơi nhiều ờ thì thì quay lại đây
một tí Ờ
thì tại sao tự nhiên anh phải nhắc cái
đoạn đấy bởi vì cái bên này này thì giả
sử bây giờ Đơn Đây là đơn hàng chi tiết
kiểu hóa đơn chi tiết ấy thì à hóa đơn
này và hóa đơn chi tiết này thì em nên
lưu lại cả mã loại phòng trong này và
giá luôn cũng được đấy để về sau mình
xem lại lịch sử mình hoàn toàn để biết
được là các thứ thứ Ờ tổng số như
anh đang nói thì bởi vì bởi vì em thực
em lựa tổng số phòng nó nửa hai nửa giờ
không biết là người ta nhìn vào tổng số
phòng này làm gì Nhưng mà theo góp nhìn
của anh thì thầy xem
ào không biết đôi khi mình lưu mình phải
biết lý do tại sao mình lưu đúng không
Ờ tính ra thì kiểu để biết được là chuẩn
là mình sẽ đặt bao nhiêu phòng thường
bao nhiêu phòng vip các thứ các thứ nó
hợp lý hơn kiểu tổng số phòng tất cả
đang hơi khó hiểu cái này thôi Ngày
check in ngày check out Thực ra vẫn
A cái này cái này vẫn thiếu đấy thì em
vẫn đang là vẫn là vẫn đang chỉ dừng ở
mức lý thuyết thực ra thực tế nó khác
thực tế đấy Cái từ thực tế nó sẽ bao gồm
đây đó là thời gian check in thực tế và
thời gian check out thực tế Bởi vì bởi
vì là chắc gì nó đã kiểu check in check
cái check in check out này là lúc nó
đăng ký mà đúng không thc Chắc gì kiểu
thực tế nó đã check in check out đúng
vào cái lúc đấy em hiểu không nên cũng
phải sửa lại cái này số ngày ở Ừ cái này
thực sự hoàn toàn có thể không cần Hoặc
là em phải quy ra quy là gì nh thời gian
các thứ các thứ thay vì số ngày bởi vì
đấy gia sự là bây giờ
anh anh check out muộn hơn bình thường
thì thực ra không tính trong ngày nữa mà
sẽ phải quy ra số giờ s thậm chí là số
giờ phạt Nói chung là
ờ đây tôi đang dựa vào cái database của
bạn này để nói qua là mình có mình có
thể nâng cấp và cải thiện nhiều thế nào
để để thực tế thực tiễn hơn với cái bài
toán Còn nếu mà giả sử Giả sử là bạn đấy
chỉ muốn dừng lại ở mức sửa kiểu làm th
này và sửa lại thôi giống nh thì thì đây
để xem nhá Ờ muốn câu truy vấn in tất cả
các
khoảng thời gian đúng không Thì Ờ bạn
đấy đang dùng nhá thì là not in như thế
này tôi không thích kiểu not in kiểu như
này bởi vì nó suby bạn cứ Hình dung là
như th này tương đương với việc là câu
select của của bạn cứ mỗi đến đến một
bản ghi nó sẽ quét lại cái bảng này một
phát này để kiểu kiểm tra xem nó có tồn
tại hay không tồn tại nằm trong này hay
không xong rồi Tiếp lại bán khi Thứ hai
lại quét lại trong này thằng ngy sẽ biến
thành bảng tạm đấy nếu mà chạy câu truy
vấn này thì sẽ kiểu thế thì không nên
như thế đúng không
Ờ để xem Jo
Phòng
năng trạng thái đơn là một tức là giả sử
trạng thái đơn này là trạng thái Cứ cho
là đã duyệt đúng không
Ờ đợi tì ở
tất cả các phòng nhá
Ờ gọi là bây giờ hiện tại đang Không
đang gọi là đang trống đúng không Thì
mình sẽ ghi câu chuy vấn như nàoo Ờ để
tôi xem là bây giờ sẽ dùng phần mềm gì
để ghi câu truy vấn rồi không thì dùng
luôn p stor
m cài thêm vài tiện í mà
Ờ
select Ừ cứ sản sử là sao
đi
sẽ thu nhỏ cái màn này lại
đó đổi thằng này thành
select sa
form loại phòng này à đâu form phòng chứ
phòng
này Jo với giả sử là muốn cho cái này
bạn ấy đang muốn là liệt kê cái danh
sách kiểu các phòng đang còn trống thì
sẽ loại phòng
chid
bằng Phong chid loại
Nhưng mà thực ra không hạn chế nử anh đ
Việt kể này tôi thường ghi là mã hơn
ờ xong rồi Bây giờ Bây giờ giả sử để đầu
tiên để lấy tất cả phòng đang đặt tại
thời điểm hiện tại là nhá thì sẽ là form
đật phòng đúng không choi à gán phòng
đúng không on đặt phòng
chấm
ID Đặt phòng
bằng gán Phòng
chấm ID à
đâu đây nhầm nhầm
nhầm ID như này đúng chưa thì đây là lấy
toàn bộ những cái ID đây
ID bây giờ mình sẽ như này thì lấy toàn
bộ những cái ID Phòng đã được đặt đúng
không Rồi bây giờ mình sẽ
que ngày check in
gian nào đó đâu để xem nào
tôi từng làm đoạn này nó hơi bị dị dị
như này tí bây giờ giả sử bây giờ các
bạn cứ Hình dung là bây giờ có một cái
giao diện để cho khách hàng đây tôi cho
mấy ông Xem giao diện
Đặt phòng khách sạn
giả sử ở đây là chọn loại phòng hoặc là
không kiểu số phòng các thử thử đúng
không ạ
ờ ừ còn số phòng nữa cơ còn lằng nhằng
hơn nữa cơ ô vẫy chưởng Ờ Giả sử là ông
đặt như này ông sẽ được chọn khoảng thời
gian này đến khoảng thời gian này đúng
chứ kiểu như này đúng không ạ Đây kiểu
kiểu như này giả sử là 24 đến 30 chẳng
hạn đúng chứ Giả sử bỏ qua việc chọn cái
này đã nhá Thì cái khoảng thời gian này
truyền vào thì tức là cái phòng đấy phải
trống trong khoảng thời gian từ này thế
này đúng không Tức là sao nghĩa là ông
truyền ở đây sẽ có hai cái biến hai cái
tham số một cái là thời gian bắt đầu và
một cái thời gian kết thúc đúng không
Thì thì Cái quan trọng là
đây tức là mình phải ghi sao cho mà nó
cái thời gian bắt đầu với thời gian kết
thúc không được giao với cái thời gian
mà khách đã chọn à khách đã đặt Tức là
sao nghĩa là giả sử Tôi có một cái biến
là time start
này và time end chẳng hạn hai cái biến
này đúng
không Thì rõ ràng
là tôi vẽ r. cho mấy ông hình dễ hình
dung nhá Tôi cũng đang không hình dung
được nên tôi cứ phải vẽ lại chong chính
tôi hình dung
đi đây đây rõ ràng là đây là thời gian
Đây là thời
mùng một
đến
đúng không Thì tôi có tôi kiểu gì Một là
tôi sẽ phải
khách đã là từ mùng 1 đến mùng 10 đúng
chứ thì tôi chỉ có thể đặt là từ à Thôi
đây sẽ từ mùng 3 đến mùng 10 đi thì tôi
sẽ phải đặt kiểu mùng 1 đến mùng 2 thôi
Đúng chưa nó chỉ được đặt từ 1 đến mùng
2 thôi như
đây hai là tôi sẽ phải đặt là từ 11 đến
một ngày nào đó trong tương lai đúng chứ
mày Ông hiểu ý tôi không Ví dụ ngày 11
đến ngày kiểu 20 thì tôi đặt được đúng
không đúng
chứ chứ không thể nào mà mình đặt từ
mùng 1 đến mùng 9 được tức cả nó chỉ là
đây
Ờ tôi phải kéo cái này ra góc này cho
mấy không dễ hình dung
này tôi cái cái này nó không thi Giao
vào cái này được nó không thể kiểu nhảy
sang mùng Chí Được đúng chứ đây không
thể cái này thành mùng chí được thanh
sai đúng không Tức là ngày kết thúc mà
nằm trong phạm vi này sai đúng không
Hoặc là ngay bắt đầu ngay bắt đầu
đây lại nằm trong phạm vi này cũng sai
đúng không ng bắt đầu nằm trong phạm vi
này cũng sai đúng chưa hoặc là thậm chí
là chắc chắn là nm gì có trường hợp mà
kiểu cả ngày cả cả ngày bắt đầu cả ngày
kết thúc nằm trong Phạ vi này đúng không
Đúng chưa Thế chắc chắn là càng sai đúng
chưa này thêm một trường hợp nữa này đây
sẽ là mùng 5 cho đến mùng 7 đúng chứ Đấy
thì rõ ràng là cái này có ba bài toán
Cần xử lý thì ông giải quyết từng bài
toán một đã đó thứ nhất là ngày bắt đầu
này phải à Chính xác là ngày kết thúc
này ngày kết thúc nhá phải làm phải nhỏ
hơn ngày bắt
đầu hoặc hoặc ngày kết thúc à hoặc ngày
bắt đầu phải lớn lớn hơn ngày kết thúc
đúng
chứ và đương nhiên là đương đương nhiên
là chắc chắn là mình sẽ phải kiểm tra là
ngày bắt đầu này phải nhỏ hơn ngày kết
thúc rồi đúng không ngĩa đầu tiên là cái
cái việc mà ông kiểm tra kiểm tra time
start nhỏ hơn Tam Cái này là code Ông
kiểm tra rồi trong code chứ không phải
phải ông vào trong fql ông mới kiểm tra
cái vụ này đúng chưa Thì bây giờ rõ ràng
là ông chỉ cần cái ngày đây là ngày
check in là bản thân bản thân là ngày
bắt đầu này đúng không Thì rõ ràng là
ngày ngày bắt đầu này này nó sẽ phải lớn
hơn cái ngày kết thúc này của ông Đúng
chưa Nó sẽ
là không Phả lớn không phải lớn hơn bằng
được nó sẽ time and này
and ngày check out đúng không
phải ngy check out này này phải nhỏ hơn
cái time start của ông Đúng
Tôi nói thế này mới không hiểu
không Nếu mà kiểu ngay chck ngay check
in lớn hơn time thì rõ ràng nó sẽ lớn
hơn time start rõ ràng hiển nhiên nó sẽ
lớn hơn time start này bởi vì rõ ràng là
time lớn hơn time start rồi đúng không
Thì có phải là là cái này nó sẽ kéo
xuống đây đúng không và tương tự là nếu
mà nếu mà ngày check out nhỏ hơn hst thì
cái này kéo về đây thì sẽ không thì sẽ
không có trường hợp này s ra luôn cái
trường hợp thứ ba này Thực ra là nó
không phải xảy ra bởi vì mình đã kiểm
tra hai cái này rồi ok không
ồi tự nhiên tôi dạy cái này cái này cũng
liên quan đến toán đấy mấy ông ạ Mấy ông
kém toán hừa trước chịu nhá Đấy thì đấy
thì mấy ông sẽ phải kiểm tra như này Đây
là kiểm tra việc là cái này nhưng à quên
quên quên quên mất quên mất tôi tôi cuốn
hơi cuốn quá Tôi quên mất mất cái này
mình đang lấy
A lấy phòng đang đặt cơ mà lỗi tôi lỗi
tôi
thời gian này mới
chọn thì mình phải ngược lại quên quên
quên mất quên mất ờ
bây giờ sẽ có hai
cách một là lấy được thời gian có thể
đặt
ờ quên quên quên quên tôi lỗi tôi lỗi
tôi cuốn quá mãi vẽ này quốn quá quên
mất ờ
lấy khoảng thời thực ra là chắc chỉ một
cách thôi không phải hai cách Bởi vì
hiển nhiên là mình sẽ chỉ lấy mình chỉ
nên quan tâm đế việc là lấy phòng đang
đặt trong khoảng thời gian cách chọn chứ
mình không phải lấy phòng đang đặt trong
khoảng thời gian khách không chọn
ờ À không phải nh khách không à Lấy
phòng đang trống đang trống trong khoảng
thời gian khách chọn thì thực ra thì có
rất nhiều Phòng đang trống lúc đấy cái
việc là là cái đặt phòng này nó sinh ra
là thám chỉ là là kiểu gì đã được đặt
rồi mà thì điều đấy là điều kiểu nghe nó
vô lý thì nó lại là cái bài toán mình đã
xử lý mất rồi nên là nên là chỉ lấy cái
phòng đang đặt trong thời gian khách
chọn với chuột thì cái này sẽ phải sửa
lại đ là tôi nhớ rồi thì tức là là mình
sẽ lấy toàn bộ những cái trường hợp 1 2
ba này này để để sao cho đương nhiên vẫn
phải kiểm tra đoạn này nhá vẫn phải kiểm
tra đoạn này tránh việc kiểu logic sai
thì thì mình lấy trường hợp một cả cả
mấy cái trường hợp này này để để kiểu
gọi là trường hợp mà không được phép
được đặt ấy thì mình We not in trong cái
danh sách đấy là được ok thì tức là cái
thằng Trường hợp một là thằng
trường hợ 1 là cứ lấy theo ở trên nữ nhá
đó là thằng tim start này này nằm trong
phạm vi nằm trong khoảng thời
gian check in và check out Đúng chưa Cứ
sửa lại nhá là ngày check in
này lớn hơn bằng bằng được nhá Đúng
không time start bởi vì hoàn toàn là
thằng này có thể thằng này hoàn toàn có
thể đặt từ ngày mùng 3 mà đúng
không
đúng chư hoàn toàn thể
mà thậm chí là mình sẽ còn có cả trường
hợp Thứ tư
cơ tôi vẽ cho trườ hợp thứ tư Giả sử
thằng ấy đặt từ tận m một cho đến tận
ngày 15 được mà nghĩa là nó sẽ chứa luôn
cả này cơ Đợi tí nhưng mà mình cứ làm
Tần lượt lại đây trong trường hợp en này
ngày check out
này nhỏ hơn
à không phải nhỏ đâu rồi đợi tí
Ờ nhỏ hơn bằng time n giả giả sử đấy
trường hợp 1 đúng không Đây nghĩa tức C
thằng này hoàn toàn thể ngắn lại bằng
như
này đấy hoặ Thằng này có thể dài ra như
này đúng chư tùy đây trường hợp 1 đúng
không thôi Tí mình sẽ rút gọn lại Bây
giờ mình cứ ghi hết tất cả trường hợp đã
o này hoặc này Đấy tiếp
là cái thằng này sẽ nằm ở giữa đúng
không Thì sẽ
là ngày check
in lớn hơn hoặc bằng à đâu phải nhỏ hơn
hoặc bằng th này và ngay à đâu đợi đợi
đợ đợi thì tôi lúm m rồi rồi đây sẽ
là vẫn là nhỏ hơn bàn th
đâu lớn hơn là bằng time start và nhỏ
hơn bằng time end Ơ cái trường hợp này
có khi bằng trường hợp này luôn rồi
trường hợp này bằng trường hợp này rồi
độ gì
Ừ đây ngày trước in lớn hơn hoặc bằng
time start đây này và nhỏ hơn bằng time
À tôi hiểu tại sao rồi Thôi ghi đoạn này
vẫn thiếu ghi cái trên nó vẫn thiếu bả
sao nó gộp luôn cả hai đợi
tí đầu tiên trong trường hợp này nhá
ngày check in này lớn hơn bằng tim
này lớn bằng time start và ngay check
out lớn hơn hoặc
bằng à nhỏ hơn bằng th Ok
Ok đoạn này vẫn đúng vẫn đúng không sai
chẳng qua đoạn này tôi viết tắt hơn một
tí
thôi Tại sao tôi lại nói tôi viết
tắt thi toán ở đây Cần xử lý Á
ghi lại bài toán đây nhá
phòng
đang trống trong khoảng thời
gian gọi
là
à khách chọn khách sẽ chọn là truyền vào
Time start và time end đấy
Ờ
đoạn này tôi viết tắt một tí một bước
nên thành ra là nó trông có vẻ sai à
Trông có vẻ là kiểu khi mà kiểu w Kate
lên tạo thằng mới thì thì thành sai
Ờ đoạn này chuẩn Cái ngày check out này
nhỏ hơn bằng th thì đúng nghĩa là bản
chất là thằng này nó đang ôm luôn cả cái
thằng này rồi gọi thằng này này bản chất
là đang ôm luôn cả thằng này nếu viết
theo kiểu này mế không hiểu không
Nếu không hiểu là cái đoạn này
này ông đúng kiểu ông đang nối thẳng
thằng ông đang nối thêm một thằng nữa
này Từ đây vào
ơ vẽ một thằng nữa ông nối thằng một
thằng time start à ngày Check in cho đến
Time tamen đây kiểu này ngày check in
đến Time bởi vì Viết như này nếu viết
liền thì nó là như này đúng không ngày
check in
này xong rồi có phải đến Time start đúng
không x rồi có phải đến ngày check
out Xong rồi
đến
Time đúng không Thế là tôi từng chữa bài
toán này chong mấy ông rồi phải chẳng
qua tôi lâu làm không làm tôi quên đấy ờ
đúng không nếu viết theo kiểu này thì có
phải là như này đúng chứ đúng không Nó
là trường 1 đấy đúng không ạ
Thì bây giờ mình đang nói cái trường hợp
thôi tôi viết kiểu này cho dễ hiểu đi
rồi viết lại xong trong code chắc đỡ hơn
đấy thì mình rút gọn lại về ngày check
in và check out thì nó sẽ là thằng này
nhỏ hơn thằng này và thằng này nhỏ hơn
thằng này đúng không tiếp là Đấy đấy là
bài toán 1
nháy trường hợp 1 trường hợp hai là
thằng này nhỏ hơn thằng này và thằng này
thì nằm giữa hai thằng này đúng không
thì có phải là thằng này sẽ phải là time
start có trước đúng không x rồi đến Ngà
check in xu rồi đến
Ờ
timen trong trường hợp là thằng này ôm
mà đúng không xu rồi mới đến ngay check
out đúng không thì viết đoạn code này nó
sẽ
là ngay check in này lớn hơn hoặc bằng
time start này và ngày check out lớn hơn
hoặc bằng time
ok chưa biết kiểu này không biết đúng
nhở ng chi lớn bằng th start này ch ao
lớn bằng đúng đúng đúng đúng rồi đó Mình
ghi kiểu này chắc là ghi thành code nó
dễ hơn đúng không
Ừ tiếp tiếp cái này nếu mà muốn trường
hợp 3 thì rõ ràng là có phải là ngày
check in này đến th cách ra như này cho
mấy không dễ nhìn
nhá
trường h 1
chck in này ng check in sẽ lớn hơn time
Time S mới đến ngày check out ok chưa
mấy ông đoạn này hiểu không nhỉ cũng
không khó hiểu lắm đúng không thấy dễ mà
Thì ngày trước in phải nhỏ hơn time
start đúng
không tiếp là đến Time thì tức là ngày
check out lớn hơn time Ok đúng rồi đúng
không và trường hợp cuối là thằng thằng
này Cái thằng này này nó ôm luôn Nó lớn
hơn tất cả đúng không Thì sẽ là time
start này đến ngày check in này rồi đến
ngày checkout này rồi mới đến Time đúng
không thì đây sẽ có phải là ngày chck in
nhỏ hơn à đâu lớn hơn time start và ngày
check
out nhỏ hơn
time Đó ok không mấy ông thấy hợp lý
không Xong rồi bây giờ mình sẽ ghép lại
thằng này với thằng này nó bằng nhau
không có đúng không Đúng chưa thì đoạn
này copy
sang trường 1 và chường ợ
cái này tại cho nó có dấu bằng ấy nên
thành ra là kiểu nó sẽ có trường hợp này
xảy
ra th này hai thằng này đang bằng có thể
bằng nhau nên trường hợp này xảy ra đúng
không tiếp cái này lớn hơn này và Ừ chắc
không rốt gọn được nữa đâu đấy nó sẽ có
ba trường hợp này xảy
ra ok không mấy ông thấy hợp lý
không mấy ông thấy tôi tôi làm sai đoạn
n sai đoạn nào thì bảo nhá Không L không
xấu hổ lắm ok nhỉ Bạn em em em hỏi cái
câu này hiểu không nhỉ Này Tải kịp
rồi coi như là cứ hiểu nhá Không hiểu
thì hỏi thêm ở trong discord nhá Ờ đấy
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ đương nhiên là mình
cái này là
O các bạn nhớ để ý o nhá rất là cẩn thận
à Bởi vì o ở đây mà mình mình ở đây ghi
thêm e là coi như là toàn bộ những cái O
này nó sẽ thay cả cái n này nên tất cả
cái này mình sẽ phải nằm trong một cái
ngoặc tròn nào đó đây
rồi đoạn này em hiểu đúng không Chắc anh
tạm xóa đoạn này đi để viết thành code
cho dễ nhá Mấy ông không mấy ông cần để
ý thì chắc xem lại sau nhá tất cả đoạn
này em bản chất em PH vẫn phải nằm trong
một cái ngặc tròn to này
này
đấy đấy xong mày e này tiếp
ngày check out nhỏ hơn bằng time n vẫn
giống hệt cái cái một
mà À đâu Ngày chck
in đúng đúng đúng rồi vẫn đúng ngày
chick in lớn hơn bằng tim start lớn hơn
bằng mà thằng này nó lớn hơn thằng này
đúng
này nó phải lớn hơn n số này lớn hơn hơn
số này đúng không Đấy em cũng bị nhầm
lúc đầu giống anh đấy số này phải lớn
hơn số này đúng không số 3 phải lớn hơn
số 1 đúng không Thì chẳng là lớn hơn
đúng không và 15 thì đương nhiên lớn hơn
số 10 đúng không Thì có phải là th men
phải lớn hơn ngày trcka đúng không anh
đang ghi nó kiểu thành xuôi như này
nhưng mà nên là kiểu nhìn trông khó đọc
thôi đúng
xong
Ôi giật
mình
Ờ tiếp theo là là
ừ
ok hình dung được rồi đúng không Nếu
không hình dung được rồi thì chắc là làm
tiếp thôi thì thì bạn đấy bạn đấy cần
thêm là kiểu trạng thái đơn đúng không
trạng thái đơn kiểu đã duyệt chẳng hạn
thì mình lên cái trạng thái ở đây bằng 1
tức cả đã duyệt thì đây Có phải toàn bộ
Cái này là lấy ra tất cả những cái
phòng được đặt trong khoảng thời gian mà
khách đã chọn đúng chứ
gì nữa không
nhỉ còn thêm cả loại phòng hay cái gì gì
đó thì thì chắc là làm nâng cấp sau làm
nâng cao sau loại phòng thì bản chất là
mình phải join sang
cái này này
Ờ bạn đây tôi sẽ D dạy lại mấy ông về
cái Joy của
SQL
một cách giống như bạn ấy vừa nãy làm nó
là bạn ấy sẽ làm là qu Phong chid not in
trong cái danh sách cả cái Cụng cái danh
sách này đúng chư đấy Kiểu kiểu như này
đấy như này đúng không ạ thì như tôi đã
nói thì thế này là nó duyệt qua lần lượt
từng cái một và thằng sq nữa nó không hề
Tối ưu cho subquery cái đấy gọi là
subquery tức là em có một câu select nằm
trong một câu select khác thì tức là
subar
đấy thì thì nó không tối ưu thế nó tối
ưu cái gì nó tối ưu cho join là nhiều
nhất thế Bây giờ mình join vào á th mình
phải join như nào thì mấy ông xem lại
hình này nhá m ông xem lại hình này
đấy Cái này chên m à Không khác gì máy
nhở đấy thì mấy ông muốn lấy muốn lấy
thằng A thôi bỏ qua thằng b giả sử là
mình khai báo thằng a trước xong mình
cho thằng B nhưng mình muốn bỏ qua toàn
bộ những cái liên quan thằng B đúng chứ
thằng B là thằng phám đã được đặt mà
đúng không Đây là đ Đây ạ Nếu giả sử
là hình này này Jo LP Jo bình thường như
này này lấy tất cả phòng bao gồm cả
phòng đã được đặt và phòng chưa được đặt
Còn nếu mà mình join phòng với cái đặt
phòng nhưng mà nhưng mà
onw keyon này này thì sẽ lấy ra được tất
cả phòng chưa được đặt đấy Ở đấy tôi có
dạy qua mấy không về cái bài này rồi thì
bây giờ mình sẽ chỉ đơn giản là như này
mình sẽ l Joy cả cụm này luôn Cái này là
joice sub table
chất cái này cũng là một cái table time
một cái bảng tạng được chưa mình sẽ
là mình đặt tên là gì cũng được đặt
phòng cũng được không sao cả đấy xong
rồi mình on Đặt phòng
cứ bằng đã
chấm ID như này bởi vì mình vẫn th kiểu
như này xong đó thì mình mới
qu đặt
phòng chấm ID bằng à đâu Cái này ID
phòng nhá ID phòng quên mất ID phòng ha
phòng IS như này là xong đó thì ông sẽ
lấy được tất cả những
phòng không được đặt trong khoảng thời
gian này Ok
chưa
hả Nam Hồng ns ns là cái gì và Sao lại
hỏi là ở Nam Hồng chưa nghe bao giờ chắc
không phải
thì nó sẽ thực thi o xong rồi mới o đúng
không kiểu n o Thực ra là anh không nhớ
V vụ Kiểu cái nào thực thi trước nhưng
anh biết được là là nếu mà giả sử không
có đóng ở ngoặc cái này đúng không thậ
sự mà đây có những cái O như
chỉ cần chạy cái này đầu tiên này chạy
lần lượt Tứ trái ch không phải thôi chạy
cái này thứ hai mà cái này hợp lệ bởi vì
cái này là o rồi nó bằng cấp với cái
thằng e này tức là là thằng này nó đúng
luôn Không Quan Tâm thằng en cuối cùng
nữa đấy do mình sẽ phải có thêm cái
ngoặc tròn r đây đấy sợ o như này không
sao
rồi nhưng nó không đọc được cho nên in
ra toàn bộ phòng nữa Thế á Em thử lại
xem hoặc là chắc là tí anh kiểu kiểu kết
nối máy sang cho chứ Làm đoạn này thế
này Hợp lý rồi mà đây thì em hiểu về cái
join à Nó phải le join nhá Nếu em inner
Joy thì cái này chả nghĩa gì cả em phải
le Joy xong rồi em mới que kiểu in nô
như này mới
mà Đây đây đây là cách truy
vấn
demo này thôi còn test thực tế chắc là
tôi phải có DB tôi mới test được Thì đấy
là chữa
cho Ừ chắc là t t xong Thực ra tí xong
ra anh cũng phải ăn nữ chứ là để mai
hoặc hôm khác anh sẽ thử kết nối sang
máy các bạn để mà chữa trực tiếp thì lúc
đấy rõ hơn thì nhắc các bạn luôn là nếu
mà các bạn bây giờ thường là tôi không
dùng team view hay Ultra view nữa Từ hồi
dùng Win là tôi đã quen dùng cái any
deses này mấy ông có thể dùng cài được
trên khá nhiều máy nhiều hệ điều hành
hình như có cả l nus thì phải Ờ miễn phí
không quảng cáo gì cả
ờ thì mấy ông có thể cài cái này và tôi
b thường ha dùng cái này để kết nổ máy
sang máy người khác chứ không dùng team
view ha Ultra view hay cái gì khác đấy
Cái này tôi thấy khá là ổn này mấy ông
có thể cài đấy Bây giờ
thì bây giờ chắc là chữa xong cái này
còn cái gì
nhỉ Ông này chưa Nhắn lại ông trả lời
xong nhưng
mà chưa nhắn lại để sửa chắc là cần ông
này trao đổi lại sao à alo
em còn mấy này chắc là chưa cần cần chữa
thêm cái gì cả Ok Ờ Vừ chữa xong một bạn
cứ chờ tạm xong đi
Ờ Tải máy ảo và setup các thứ được không
Thì hôm trước tôi có nói thì kiểu dạng
chưa À đây tư vấn thiết kế
database Ui giời
ôi Lại lại cái bài toán là về mỗi màu
sắc một sii một giá
ch xem
cái này
product option này product
Này bạn này làm chi tiết phết chứ tỏ là
cũng gọi là cũng chạy gọi là từng trải
rồi friend ID category các thứ thứ Soo v
c v này Thực ra là sau nên tách ra bảng
riêng để xem thống kê cụ thể là các thứ
Nói chung là mấy cái thống kê Này này
nên ở bảng riêng bảng chung này là thống
kê tổng thì nó không không áp dụng được
mấy thực tế là em sẽ quan tâm V việc là
trong khoảng thời gian này nó bán được
bao nhiêu nó được xem bao nhiêu thì và
về sau nếu mà nó giảm bất thường mình
kiểm tra chứ không không lưu tổng như
này lưu tổng như này th ra là thống kê
này nó bị mơ hồ lắm em chẳng xác định
được cái gì cả
có bảng sai
kiểu đây B in ăn sai luôn có bằng sai
Thì mình để kiểu hot code cũng
được Price s Price
in default
nối sang cái product option
này nhưng mà đặt tên là sai đi được à
Không à colid nhn cả sai đ à Rồi rồi rồi
thế rồi Ơ đấy xem
nó
vẫn nhưng mà em đang muốn hỏi cái gì
product valion thì nó sẽ dễ hơn cái này
thường tách ra như này code là chỉ để
gọi như để về sau mình dễ quản lý phải
có bao nhiêu màu và bao nhiêu size và
mình gọi là mình que thì nó cũng dễ join
sang Nhưng mà thường là ở công ty anh
chẳng hạn thì đây là product varant Mình
sẽ lưu một cái varion key ra nữa xong
rồi khi filter thì mình sẽ
filter Thực ra filter cũng gọi
nhở Thực ra filter để mà Lọc ra những
sản phẩm có những cái màu này thì nó
cũng hơi khó nếu mà varion như kiểu
Ờ hoặc là theo cỡ nào đó thì hơi khó nếu
mà ông lưu theo kiểu von
vẫn có cái lợi của nó nhá Đó là ví dụ
Giả sử là tôi tôi làm cái web pan tram
tự tách ra mà Bởi vì để cho ông về sau
ông lọc Tìm kiếm ông lọc theo kiểu là
đấy đấy ví dụ là cỡ size S chẳng hạn thì
sẽ sẽ kiểu đầu tiên là ông sẽ hiển ra
hiển thị ra được cái danh sách để mà tìm
kiếm để mà chọn vào ý đấy Khi mà chọn
vào SS thì sẽ kiểu sẽ
nối sẽ kiểu biết được ID nó xong sẽ join
vào được cái bảng product option này
xong rồi Kiểu We trong cái ID đấy đúng
không làm được mà bạn làm kiểu này cũng
giống như là cái pan cham Tôi đang làm
thôi như là tôi thấy là kiểu cũng cũng
được rồi bạn muốn hỏi cái gì ấy nhỉ ny
tôi cũng lưu một cái là prod option này
này khác gì đâu cũng option ID này nhưng
tôi lưu lại thẳng cái value vào trong
này bởi vì bảng option của tôi nó sẽ chỉ
kiểu như này thôi là name này thôi name
và unit thôi không value mà mình lưu vào
trong này nế tôi không lưu value hẳn là
cái bảng riêng làm gì cả Bởi vì bảng vì
value này có bao giờ thay đổi mấy đâu
Nhưng bạn làm kiểu đấy cũng có cái hay
của bạn đấy Đó là cũng cũng là một cách
cũng là một cách đấy Ừ cũng là một cách
kiểu để mà để mà kiểu dạng là hiển thị
ra cái phần tìm kiếm là hiển thị ra tất
cả các màu V tất cả các size đấy cái
việc là khi mà khi mà người
dùng người dùng kiểu thêm mới tạo mới
đây Tôi cho ông xem mấy ông đôi khi
không hình dung được thì tôi cứ phải
demo thì m dễ hình dung
quên mất để tôi sẽ nốt lại để hỏi xếp
tôi tôi sẽ dùng cái Microsoft to do để
tôi nốt lại những cái cái thứ tôi muốn
hỏi mai
sẽ hỏi
sao logo chạy
Ờ l nun lỗi xứ
rồi đoạn này B kiểm tra lỗi Ừ cái lỗi
hôm trước cứ tạm Ừ mình chơi cách lách
là mình cứ tạm xóa cái đoạn nào chưa
dùng đi đã Để mình nhảy sang cái
Trang nhảy sang cái Trang
đấy Tại sao copy bị
có cái hiển thị ra tất cả các các cái
này tất cả cái này Thực ra là tôi lại
đang lấy từ trong bảng product để lấy ra
thì nó cũng có cái lợi có ưu vào nhược
của nó cả thôi Cái vụ này là tôi đang
phải dùng distance Ừ thì theo cách của
bạn đấy vừa rồi nó hay
mà nhỉ bảng aribo chung là như nào
nhỉ Bạn thử nói cấu trúc ở bảng đấy xem
tôi hình dung được
tôi bấm vàở đây tôi sẽ Lọc ra được đương
nhiên là bây giờ chỉ có một loại áo n
Giả sử vì sau nhiều mình sẽ tìm kiếm
được cái đoạn này là tôi lại phải lấy ở
trong
bảng product option của tôi để lấy
ra những tôi distance tất cả các cái
value này để lấy lần lượt ra còn cách
của bạn đấy có vẻ hay hơn tôi thấy ha
hơn có thể tôi xem cân nhắc và tôi sẽ
sửa lại đó là kiểu tách hẳn riêng ra như
này thì mình sẽ hiển thị ra được cái
danh sách này danh sách tất cả màu sắc
và danh sách tất cả K kích thước nhưng
mà nhược điểm như tôi vừa nói thì đó là
sẽ có lúc mà bạn liệt kê ra như thế
nhưng bạn bấm vào thì nó sẽ chẳng trả ra
cái kết quả gì cả vì rõ ràng là cái này
Chỉ liệt kê toàn bộ những cái gọi là khả
dụng thôi chứ còn thực tế là product có
những cái option đấy thì chưa chắc đúng
không sẽ nên là cách của tôi cũng đang
có một cái phần nào đó hay là nó sẽ gọi
nhỉ nó đang lấy ra tất cả nó đang lấy từ
thẳng bảng product mà nĩa Chắc chắn là
những cái cái cái này nó có product
rồi nhưng tôi nghĩ là thực ra là cái cái
nào có Yu vào Nhược nên là tôi tôi nghĩ
vẫn sẽ ố ốp theo cách của bạn này bởi vì
tôi nếu mà hạn cái những câu truy vấn ấy
các bạn sẽ để Ý là mình sẽ hôm trước tôi
đọc lại cái vụ đấy Đó là mình sẽ hạn chế
kiểu dùng cái distance
này
dist diston hình như tôi cũng đọc sai Nó
là khoảng cách dist Nó là cái gì distin
à Cái gì
nhỉ Cái nào khiến cho câu chy vấn nó bị
nặng nữa nhá qu mất rồi
à Ừ offset cũng rất là nặng Ừ
Không thực ra Windows function là hình
như là chuyên
bên Ms mssql hơn anh lại không làm bên
đấy mấy đúng không nhỉ My SQL có Windows
function không
nhỉ Có bây giờ cũng có nữa này nhưng mà
không biết mình có dùng Hình như là chưa
Ừ đúng rồi anh chưa dùng
thật cái này cũng gọi là m nó mới chắc
là mới có thì phải không hẳn là mới rất
mới nhưng mà nói chung là đâu hỏi
Charity xem
2018 bây giờ là năm 5 năm
trước 5 năm
năm trước mình vẫn đang đi dậy nhưng mà
mình lại không tìm hiểu sâu về cái này Ừ
thế là lỗi của mình để tôi nốt lại tôi
tìm hiểu dần về cái vụ này biết đầu lại
áp dụng được nhiều hơn chứ hồi trước là
tôi biết là được trong SQL Server các th
thứ Nên là tôi thường kiểu không chú Tâm
v cái đấy lắm vì tôi nghĩa là nó không
áp dụng cho toàn bộ tất cả
thêm bảng
ib value sau đó thêm bảng pivot
cho
Tôi chưa hiểu Ý ông lắm nó khác gì với
thiết kế của bạn này bạn sẽ thì đây là
bảng attribute và đây attribute value
đây bảng pivot đấy Đây chính cá bảng
pivot đấy bởi vì bảng pivot này của bạn
đấy Bạn muốn lưu lại giá xong các th thứ
nữa Và thậm chí là cái ảnh nữa thì biết
được là kiểu
nào em định hỏi cái gì ấy nhở
sao mỗi màu sắc hoặc sii một
giá là như nào nh nghĩa màu sắc này sẽ
có giá riêng á như thế Em chỉ có thể cập
nhật nhiều cái cùng một lúc
thôi cập nhật toàn bộ à Đấy do em có
thêm cái value ở đây à à Không value đ
đâu phải xem
nà
Ừ để sao value này là value khác đây là
name
valu nhỉ Tôi đang chưa hiểu cái đoạn này
không á không thế này ổn rồi Như tôi
chưa hiểu cái name và value của ông khác
nhau đm gì khi mà tha của ông nó sẽ là
kiểu color hoặc là size rồi đúng không
Thì rõ ràng ví dụ là name
là name là cỡ S chẳng hạn thì value cũng
là s mà đúng không nó khác gì
quả hôm trước hôm trước đ làm rở cái vụ
này rất là ngu si hôm trước mất cả một
buổi gần gần hai tiếng đồng hồ để ngồi
thêm cái này vào Ơ bây lỗi rồi Tuyệt
vời lại thêm lỗi lại thêm việc để làm
thử ví dụ cụ thể hơn
xem anh có khóa học có em xem trên
playlist của anh
xịn không xịn không chư tồn thời gian
vải trưởng cho cái thằng
này cho anh bé lại đi À đấy chữ gì gì gì
đó Ở đây đúng không Đó Chưa hiểu cái ul
này À đúng rồi không đấy nhớ hình như là
ul này để bấm vàoo để nhảy ra cái gì gì
đó Nhưng bây giờ không cần bỏ đi thi kế
này hơi sai sai không cần cái ul này xem
nào
Ồ à đợi tôi một tí tôi còn hôm nay tôi
biết rồi Tôi chưa kéo code mới về đăng
nhập kth nào mà đang nhập sợ bị hack
không nhỉ Chắc không đu đợi tôi một tí
nhá Đợi tôi tí tôi đang bởi vì cái git
Hub của tôi đang yêu cầu đăng nhập đ như
Ừ rồi t đợi tôi một tí
size S nó phù hợp bao nhiêu kg hoặc dài
rộng ý ạ không Nếu thế em phải có một
Bảng size gai khác không phải là lưu ở
trong bảng
này bảng xe gai nó n nà giống như là của
anh thường bạn anh thấy là ý tưởng khá
hay của thằng C này này Anh TH định bắt
trước bên
đ xem thử nhá này thì em xem cái bảng
hướng dẫn chọn size này này cái này bản
chất nó lưu ở trong một cái bảng khác
cái bảng gì đây là Bảng size G này
[âm nhạc]
mình 80 cân cao như th này thì như th
này sẽ hợp lý đấy đây bảng x gai thì em
sẽ nối
sang
bảng option bây giờ đâu
này không hẳn là khoai lắm đâu thiết kế
này vẫn làm được mà tôi chắc là về sau
tôi lại dạy mới về cái này ờ khi mà cảm
thấy có nhu cầu đến nhưng mà thực ra cái
trang web của tôi này thì nó không phải
chuyên về mỗi bán hàng quần áo nên là
tôi không đ ý định làm cái đấy
l
you
cho mấy ông được mấy ông nhìn màn hình
mấy ông l tay máy lấy cái Token
ơ s mô này Chào
đây
tôi tạo cái cái Token này chỉ trong vòng
90 ngày thôi 90 ngày sau nên làm lại từ
đầu nó sẽ hợp
toen này full quyền luôn
vậy Ngồi tích từng cái một hơi
gì storage này xóa storage này đi không
cả Ok không Conflict
Ờ tôi đang định nói gì nhỉ À tôi quên
mất tôi sẽ cho mọi người xem
cái cái bàn phím của tôi nhưng mà nó bị
khó chịu ở góc này kéo sang góc này
nhưng mà tôi sẽ dùng obs để mà hiển thị
cái bàn phím này đợi tôi một tí Đợi tôi
phải
không tính là một cái
app nó không tính ra cái app để hiển thị
nào ra được
rồi
test thôi Đang muốn hiển thị cái bàn
phím má
[âm nhạc]
ra thì tôi sẽ nh n ở trong cái màn hình
khác nó đỡ khó chịu đỡ khó chịu cho tôi
thôi vẫn khó chịu mấy ông à đây đây đây
Ngon ta đ hay không định không đấy sẽ để
bàn phím ở góc này nhá Đấy từ tô kéo và
chỗ
Tôi định hiển thị
cái tôi định hiển thị Cái ở dưới này nữa
là kiểu cái
Ờ gọi là như một
cái một cái tiêu đề ấ tiêu đề ở dưới này
là kiểu đang đang làm đến đoạn nào ấy th
một cái dòng chữ ở đây thử xem có làm
được
không đâ Chắc phải có cái ghi chữ chứ
nhỉ
Thử
đúng
rồi Chỗ này là chỗ này là nãy giờ ta sẽ
là kiểu nền màu này hết mà nó sẽ không
phải trắng đúng không Ừ tôi nghĩ để xử
thế
thôi nghĩ nhiều làm gì đấy có cái chữ ở
trên cùng M ông sẽ biết được là đang đến
phần nào đấy
tìm được nên đành phải làm kiểu nông dân
kiểu
trước tìm cái app thì nó chỉ hiển thị
mỗi cái phím a
ờ gần như là đây đây đy trang
bấm những cái phím đặc biệt mình đã bấm
ấy chứ không phải là toàn bộ tất cả phím
không
ổn rồi Nên là chắc tạm không cần chữa gì
cả giờ mình quay lại bên này bên này thì
mình
sẽ mở
Ờ mình mở telescope lên để xem là bây
giờ tôi bấm vào đây nó sẽ truy vấn đến
đâu đúng không ạ À đây nó có cả view ở
đây để xem được là mình đang ở file nào
này mình sẽ nhảy sang
ok xóa xư cái đoạn à URL đi đúng không
Này URL xóa đi này Bye
đang dùng nữa chắc là để cuối buổi Nhá
ngồi làm th này nữ nãy giờ cũng chưa làm
xong cái gì
gì đó như này mình ấn submit sẽ nhảy đến
đâu nhỉ đã lưu tình thật đấy Chưa biết
lưu như nào Ồ được rồi này lưu ngon lành
rồi này chẳng cần phải sửa B en đúng
không Xem truy vấn thế nào
load
Này swit alert gọi kiểu này hay nhở
không biết
đấy Insert into
config nằm ở đây m này lên xem code B
bởi vì bạn ấy không làm vied nhiều ở ở B
Thực ra cũng có cái lý bạn đấy vì rõ
ràng là đây bên admin nên bạn không cần
phải vi quá kỹ TH là có thể hiểu được
nhưng mà hôm trước thì tôi bảo là mình
sẽ thứ nhất là dùng config i5 đúng
chuyên thẳng content này
luôn Xóa đi
update xong rồi trable thực ra thì cái
vụ trable này như tôi hôm trước từng nói
mấy ông là thật ra mình hạn chế hạn chế
nhất có thể là bây giờ mình sẽ gọi
trable kiểu nó sẽ đôi khi mình sẽ phát
sinh tất cả các lỗi tự nhiên là cái này
sẽ bắt hết mình sẽ không bao giờ biết
được lỗi cụ thể là cái gì kết hợp V mình
không ghi lock ở đâu cả n nó không ổn
thì mình thường
sẽ mình không nên giấu lỗi đi theo như
sếp tôi thường an nói chúng ta không nên
giấu lỗi đi mà đặc biệt là đây là bên
admin được các chẳng cần phải nhá chẳng
cần phải kỹ quá như thế
mình sẽ chỉ dựng Nghĩa là chỉ thậm chí
hiển thị ra Trang lỗi cũng được Kiểu K
Thế bên admin mà nghĩa là Hiển thị hiển
thị trang lỗi th không đúng nếu trên
production thì cũng chỉ là trang kiểu
trá tinh thôi Hay trang kiểu 500 hay cái
gì gì đó nhưng mà ý tôi ấ đó
là là nếu mà ông không trai C như thế
thì nó sẽ luôn thằng lel nó có cơ chế là
khi không CHT thế kiểu gì Nếu mà lỗi
exception Đúng không Nó sẽ tự động lock
lại vào file lock và vì sao mình sẽ kiểm
tra cái file lock đấy còn vừa việc vừa
rồi là báo lỗi trả về như thế là mình
không hề log lại nên là về sau nghĩa là
người dùng của các bạn bị lỗi thì nó
điều hướng quay lại báo lỗi cho người
dùng kiểu một cái lỗi chung chung người
dùng thì không hiểu và dep của mình thì
không bao giờ biết được lỗi thì sinh ra
có cái lỗi Nó xảy ra thì thế thì không
ổn đúng không ạ thì thường là một là các
bạn sẽ phải chỉnh lại cái file log đấy
là bắn lên đâu đó giống như là thường ở
công ty tôi bắn lên discord hoặc là
telegram n mình phát hiện được lỗi xong
rồi thông báo lỗi chung chung về người
dùng thì
tùy
đây Mình xve off Đi đ thế là xong đúng
không Đấy đơn
này à ero crate Ok cũng được cũng
được Thế thì kiểu gì chẳng điếu hướng
quay trở
lại nhở à re back sớm ok ok
vừa nãy mình vừa lỡ xóa cái
cái
rồi nên bây giờ không hiển thị cái tôi
vừa mới làm thì tôi hiển thị ra nhá mình
client này content này homepage này đấy
vừa nãy mình xóa cái này
value new rival inmate á Tên nó cứ lạ lạ
của gì nhở
này content à đây đây
cái lý do bạn đấy làm cái nút kiểu dạng
là ul nó hóa ra là như này th hiểu là ờ
có cái nút nào đó để bấm vào
được Ok Tôi hiểu
rồi
nhiên là ul bây giờ mình cho phép để
nun như tôi thấy là tự nhiên cái config
này của tôi tự nhiên c thêm ul bản chất
là nó hơi bị khó hiểu đúng không ạ
C cả
không xem chi tiết ở đây thôi còn nếu mà
giả sử bấm vào thì nhảy Sang cái bên
khác sau không cần ul để bấm vào đây
đâu nếu mà không muốn sửa database thì
sẽ ăn như
đúng không đó ok chưa
ha cũng là một cái gì đó rồi đã lên một
cái gì gì đó đây đúng không
Ừ nhớ xem lại một loạt nhá slide
này cái này mặc định slide này của tôi
slide này đang trống thành ra là kiểu bị
mất mất cái mấ cái trên cùng
trên này và bỏ ul đi cũng
được
URL bấm vào cái slide Thực ra nếu mà bây
giờ mình bỏ mình bỏ mấy cái phần ul ấy
thì tất cả gần như tất cả mấy cái ở ở
chỗ trên này gần như là xem cho vui ch
chẳng bấm được cái nào người dùng sẽ
phải bấm vào bên menu Tôi cứ tạm chấp
nhận là phải như thế chứ k u này Thực ra
nó hơi bị tối nghĩa mấy không thấy tối
nghĩa không tự nhiên lại sẽ có một cái
ul ở đây đúng không ul trong bản config
này để làm
phần ul thử thử đi
Slider inmate t thử thử ch chân chị f
Slider
này rồi tôi xóa đạn này đi
đây chọn
file hết ảnh rồi Ảnh này đi này to quá
không này hơi to
quá lấy ảnh xếp tôi đi này có khi to hơn
ấy xin lỗi xếp
thế
anh lấy ảnh em trên trang chủ em sẽ lấy
ảnh anh lên trang chủ của em chúng ta
bằng nhau bấm 1 2 3 ở đây không được có
chịu
nhỉ
read more r more để mà nhảy ra à Bởi vì
Rm ở đây chưa sửa cái
ul Ừ nhưng mà tôi vẫn muốn bỏ cái ul đi
mấy không ạ
điểm mế để ý nhá bạn đấy h dùng cái này
là đa ngôn ngữ ở bên ở bên admin mà rõ
ràng là người Việt với nhau hại sử dụng
tiếng Anh và để đa Đ ngôn ngữ còn trong
kh đó trang chủ thì để tiếng Việt tất cả
đang là tiếng Việt bắt buộc phải à tất
cả đang hot code bằng tiếng Anh nhá này
bắt buộc phải sửa lại rất nhiều không ổn
lắm không ổn lắm cái r more này ra trông
vẻ hay đấy nhưng mà tôi bảo để code để
cho thanh menu thôi Cái này chỉ hiểu đơ
giả lên bài thôi hl này nó hơi khó hiểu
t nghĩ là người dùng anh em code mình
anh em hiểu mãi về xong mới hiểu được
không biết người dùng hiểu cái gì tự
nhiên có một cái ull ở đấy đúng không
rồi này Xóa đi ơi xóa ul rồi mà nhở
à
code bạn này XL ở đây Đây là một cái
lt ra này in ra này lại ul tiếp để nhập
ul này bỏ
đi Nói chung là bạn này cũng chữ khó m
là mấy cái này trông cũng vãi chưởng
kiểu men
Woman Tại sao hot code men ở đây
nhỉ chưa hiểu cái đoạn M với Woman này
lắm xem
nào Man Woman làm gì
nhỉ
Đấy
con này Nga nữa nhở này
đi
submit lỗi à chọn cả hai như thế Chuẩn
bạn sẽ để require ở trong cái này hợp lý
hơn kiểu nó lỗi như thế cho người dùng
đúng không ạ
requir như này Đấy và trong đây
requir th hiểu được là khi submit form
này phải điền cả hai không Nó baáo lỗi
đấy như này nó sẽ hợp lý không đúng
không ạ phải tải lại trang x bắt phải
điền lại
suced đấy sẽ có như này lại
ul
ờ
every đ đi này
category vừa rồi là mình đợi tô một tí
vừa rồi Mình lưu lại
đây store category inmate đ config Cái
thứ thử như này Ờ mình chạy ở trong cái
ham
backend rồi à Ở fend
nh
này cát men đấy mấy ông xong rồi mấy ông
còn kiểu code thỉnh thoảng bị lười mấy
ông còn viết tắt vào đấy nữa chịu đấy
Không nên như thế đúng không
Ừ cái resot này bị đè lên bởi cái res
này m không thấy không đỉnh không đấy
thôi XP off Phil ngày đây cho nhanh
value config
category như thế mình sẽ config ke i5
này sẽ
có
đi gọi ý đi đậu
là thằng nếu mà thằng copilot này mà đơ
cái coi như là khỏi gợ
đấy Kiểu như này CH không lỗi đâu
Ừ
một tí không biết được cái này in là ở
đâu
đó trong một cái giao diện homepage hoàn
chỉnh ở sẽ như này trông cũng ra Gì nhỉ
ý nh là đẹp hơn giao diện Tôi tự
kem anh ấy ngồi ăn ăn mì xong để lại cái
sĩa xong rồi gi đ
Ờ đấy có vẻ Xong homepage rồi Xong hẳn
một tính năng rồi đấy xị nhở đẳng cấp
đấy Tôi tự nhận tôi đẳng cấp
Ờ cái ảnh này à đây tôi giật mình tưởng
ảnh này không cho xóa không phải chỉnh
sửa cái này thì
sao cái này cho chỉnh sửa cái ảnh này
không xóa không xóa được à đổi phile à Ừ
cũng không hay lắm nhỉ ổi Kệ
vậy bây giờ sang bên sản phẩm nhá Tôi
bảo là bây giờ mình không có đập đi đậm
lại nên là
cứ động đến đâu mình sửa dần đến đấy Uầy
đã một tiếng bốn mấy phút rồi cơa chẳng
lẽ hôm nay mình ngồi làm mỗi hom page cả
xong à hơi sai sai nhỉ À quên mất quên
mất
quên mất Hôm nay tôi sẽ dạy m ông phải
viết test không phải mỗi song giao diện
đâu ạ Chúng ta sẽ chuyển qua vi test
ạ m không hảo hứng không m không hảo
hứng không Tôi rất Hảo hứng vì tôi rất
thích kiểu gần đây kiểu Sếp tôi thường
anh nói đó là sếp tôi à Kiểu cảm thấy
viết test là một trong những cái phân
Min vĩ đại nhất
của gần nhất thì nó hơi quá một trong
những phân minh vĩ đại luôn
Tôi sẽ thử nói không Tại sao nó lại như
thế Ô cái này còn gọi update nữa này
thôi không sao Chúng ta sẽ viết test
test nó sẽ ôm hết tất cả đống này
đấy Hợp lý không bây mình sẽ
Ờ test vào trong
đây thường à đây sẽ có cái fixture và
unit unit Nếu mà tôi nhớ không lầm ấy
unit tức cả độc lập từng t cái từng cái
mảng riêng mảng riêng một và fixture thì
tức
cả fixture tức cả gọi nhỉ Là nó
sẽ theo từng tính năng và thường là tôi
sẽ code theo từng tính năng n là tôi sẽ
viết trong này Unit thì kể để đấy
Ờ nhớ không lầm là thằng đây tôi cho mấy
ông đọc lại trang chủ của larel về vest
tôi Thực ra tôi cũng chưa đọc đâu Tôi ở
công ty tôi cứ nhảy thẳng vào chứ cũng
không đọc trên trang chủ mấy nữa thì
trang chủ này nó cũng cứ kiểu không phản
là đầ đủ
lắm pet à
pet không biết test là gì chng vẻ hay
hay tìm hiểu
Ồ có stop onfu luôn này chắc là tôi sẽ
copy cái này trong vẻ hay đấy
thêm này
Đấy khi mà lỗi cái dừng luôn đỡ phải
chạy lại cái parallel này hay phết
thường là nếu mà ông chạy test như này
nó sẽ chạy lần lượt lần lượt còn
parallel này nó sẽ chạy song song với
nhau thì ông biết được là toàn bộ cái
test của ông chạy nhanh thử thử nha Ồ có
hàm recreate này database luôn đỉnh
database for
x parel process is running your
mình sẽ chạy BB shing lại để có những
cái dữ liệu gọi là những dữ liệu mặc
định ban đầu có ví dụ user nào user nào
user nào admin các thứ để chạy test hợp
lý hơn để xem nó chỉ giới thiệu này thôi
Đỉnh
making a
request đâ tôi sẽ vi test
Không nhưng mà Bởi Bọn tôi dùng là au
chứ không phải là
cái hay phết m ông có thể thấy tôi đang
đọc lướt nhiều ra tôi biết qua mấy cái
này nhiều rồi nên tôi mới đ lad kiểu như
fake đẩy lên này test cả
chắc là tôi cũng không ý định test view
đâu kệ kệ giao diện đ Xem V tting
này đây tôi định chơi cái dùng cái
refres database này
test này nó kiểu chạy xừ vào cái dữ liệu
của cái databas đang có
nên tôi mới đang phải xem lại cái vụ này
cẩn
đầu tận dụng cái Factory này mình tạo
một cái Factory cho thằng này
Đấy mình define cho nó xong
rồi xong rồi khi test thì mình chỉ cần
kiểu đây C thử thử
thử
TH có BC đây ưu sinh này Factory make th
xong rất tiện ở trong phần
này
này thằng
test
chưa động và Thằng t cy này t cy này
sẽ thêm một cái là shit bằng chu thì sẽ
luôn Chạy lại shit
ồ
các cái sher này
Ừ hợp lý đấy Hợp lý
đấy tính ra tôi còn chưa
visit Tức là mình sẽ viết Factor trước
SH xong rồi mình
mới mình mới tận dụng viết test này được
để bây giờ nãy giờ mấy ông đang thấy tôi
chỉ đọc lại tài liệu nhưng không Tôi
muốn xem lại cái bởi vì nhá bản chất là
giống như là tôi đang ở công ty thì nó
là tôi khi mà tôi viết test thế nó đang
kiểu nó sẽ Insert Hằng một cái database
hiện tại của mình đang dùng luôn và dùng
luôn cái database hiện tại của local của
các bạn ấy nó sẽ hơi bị theo tôi nó sẽ
hơ hơi bị rác dữ liệu và đôi khi nó sẽ
tạo ra mình chạy test nhiều mà ngoài
việc rác mà đôi khi C thậm chí là sai dữ
liệu bởi vì test mình lúc đầu mới ghi th
không chuẩn nên là tôi muốn là bây giờ
cái việc cái việc chạy test đấy nó tạo
tạo ra dữ liệu nhưng phải xóa dữ liệu
ngay sau khi tạo xong nên là nên là tôi
mới đang đọc cái phần này phần này thấy
nó nói khá hay theo như tôi đang hiểu
thì nó sẽ là khi mà chạy Xong nó sẽ
refres lại database m ông thấy không ạ
Nó sẽ có cái refres database này không
biết được refet hay ngôi Xóa toàn bộ
databas gốc của mình không hay là thằng
này còn đang dùng database ảo không động
và database gốc Tôi không biết được Chắc
là tôi không nói chung tài liệu của
thằng larel nó không bao giờ đầy đủ nên
thực ra mình không biết được là thằng
này đang tạo đ B Đ ảo hay chọc vào thằng
d b gốc nữa Cho xem nà Hình như là do
cấu hình nv thì phải nhớ thế T không có
à Đúng rồi chô nhớ là cấu hình nv là nv
ch testing gì vậy nv ch test ấ chắc là
tôi để tôi đọc
đây đây EV ch testing Đúng
rồi thì mình sẽ cấu hình cái cấu hình à
đây pp unit à init Cái gì đây đây đây
đây
đấy
này
[âm nhạc]
như này là là nó dùng cái database nào
cũng được tôi sẽ tạo tôi sẽ như thế Tôi
sẽ tạo hai database một database ở l là
database thật và một database chỉ là
mình sẽ kết nối database đấy để chỉ chạy
test thôi thì hợp lý nhất và mình thể
refres lại database đấy thoải mái ông
hiểu g thi không nó sẽ không động vào
cái cái d liệu của cái gốc mà mình
thường hay thao
tác nhưng mà trước đấy thì mình sẽ cần
viết shed sher
và mình sẽ viết SH
và Factory đã
Nói chung là mình cần làm nhiều thứ đấy
tôi sẽ ghi lại đây nhá tram
này Xóa đạn này thính xu tôi sẽ ghi
những thứ cần làm đã Factory đấy xong
test cái này rất là quan trọng
ở buổi sau tôi sẽ dạy về mấy thứ
này và bây giờ tôi bây giờ đến cuối buổi
rồi tôi sẽ tranh thủ nói qua là bao giờ
kết thúc dự án pancham này thì đã từng
có bạn hỏi điều đấy
thì thì dự án này tôi nói chung là tôi
sẽ cố làm cố làm thì chắc là bây giờ là
tháng 11 à Ừ chắc phải tôi không nghĩ là
Trước Tết tôi thể xong kịp bởi vì tính
ra là hai hai buổi một tuần bâ giờ có
cho là sang tháng 12 thì là tầm à à Đâu
Một Tuần hai buổi Chứ xong người gọi này
Ui xếp gọi luôn Ồ đợi đợi tì xếp Gọi
chắc có bấc gì đó rồi ồ Hôm nay chắc tạm
tan sớm An nhá chào các bạn xếp gọi rồi
nhá Bye